so
we're finishing up the semester this is
our last day of class and
we only got to do two days on thomas
aquinas which is kind of unfortunate
you could actually spend the whole
semester just going through
some of the things that we've studied in
detail
um we had to cut out the part about
virtues and
vices specifically
we did get to talk about happiness and
now we're going to talk about something
that's really central to his moral
theory that brings it all together
natural law
thomas aquinas if you have to summarize
his moral theory by giving it a sort of
title it's a natural law theory
does that mean that's all he talks about
no we're going to start out actually
talking about the eternal law
and then a couple other different kinds
of law
but this is really central to his
approach and
it is a religiously based
system of ethics
it's theologically informed
but it's a bit different than a lot of
the
sort of appeals to religion that get
made in ethics especially um
in popular ways as we see today and i'm
going to try to draw out that contrast
as we go through
so let's start actually with with the
eternal law
that's where thomas starts in
in this question question 91
he asks whether there's an eternal law
and eternal means what
lasting forever right
but eternal i actually mean something
beyond forever
if something exists in eternity that
means that it exists at all times and
places
as a matter of fact even before time
began
it would it would be there and
when you get down to it if you ask
thomas well what's the eternal law
ultimately it is
god
god has done something different
than
the law or the
reason or the structure that he gives to
things so it's not like you know god one
day said oh there people are screwing
around too much i need to make a law i'm
going to make a law and it's going to
stick for good because i'm god
um
it's not that kind of eternal law
i mean that's that's that's a sort of
popular or bulgarized version of how
things take place in the bible anyway
but that's not how thomas thinks they
take place
there's a sort of structure within god's
mind
that orients everything that understands
everything
to the good which again for thomas is
ultimately what god
and that's there before even the world
is created
so
when the world is created thomas thinks
that other things are kind of built into
it based on this
now this is a pretty lofty idea isn't it
we don't actually get to see the eternal
law
as such
um who gets who actually fully
understands the internal law and gets to
see it all the time
who do you think
if not us
well
just god right but we can grasp part of
it
we can't grasp
thomas says we can't grasp the totality
of it he says even the blessed in heaven
they don't actually see every single
thing
but you know they're better off than
those of us who are struggling down here
trying to make sense of things
so we can grasp this in part and thomas
thinks that the distinctive way in which
we human beings do this
is through the natural law
so this is what is really proper to us
and
if we go on to the next question
whether there is in us a natural law now
when we think of natural laws
what do we typically associate that with
before you came in here today or before
you actually read the reading for today
um if i said
natural law what's your first thing that
comes to mind
what would you say
pretend you haven't read any thomas
beforehand or heard any of this sort of
stuff
yeah
gravity
okay yeah we think of gravity as being a
law of nature
are there any other laws of nature that
you could
you could
think of that would come to mind
any of you science majors in here
no
well gravity will do that right what are
we saying when we use the word gravity
what's going to happen to this let me
use this example many times
it's going to fall right it better fall
and if it doesn't we think something is
drastically wrong if i just let that go
and it hung in the air you'd be looking
for a string or you'd say it's magic or
you know
i'm going to fall off the earth because
you know things are no longer sticking
to where they're supposed to be
thomas aquinas thinks that the way that
the universe is constructed physical
objects like this they do have their
laws that they follow they have a
certain regularity
um he looks into kind of an
anthropomorphic way that he's getting
from aerosol he talks about these things
having inclinations but he doesn't
really think that the eraser thinks to
itself okay what do i want to do now
i really want to fall
let me do that he thinks it just sort of
happens that way but it happens that way
because of the way god set things up
right so there is natural law in that
sense
do you think we could talk about
living things
let's start with not not even animals
just plants
how do they work
i mean we're moving into planting season
pretty soon um
what do we do here during that sometimes
you should go to lowe's or home depot
buy the plants already
formed but that's the that's the easy
way
um yeah oh i mean
you have to practice with the right soil
obviously they need like
components to survive such as like
sunlight water yeah
the plants are in some way kind of like
really complicated machines that take in
certain inputs like carbon dioxide water
nitrogen from the soil
sunlight and they
change things they manufacture things
how do we start them off
yeah we go and buy those little seed
packets if you're a farmer you buy big
seed packets right you know you can buy
those
you can buy them sometimes seeds by the
time and each one of those seeds
ought to be more or less like the other
ones
and you know it's it's kind of an
interesting concept if you think about
like a kernel of corn that's a seed
and that little kernel of form it looks
like corn in a way doesn't that good it
looks like the part that we like to eat
does it look like the whole rest of it
the stalk
the little tassel on top the roots that
are down and off the bottom
and yet that's somehow contained in that
seed
that unfolds that's part of its nature
and if you plant a corn plant you don't
expect a flower to come up do you
or
turnips or
what else a tomato plant if you plant a
tomato seed you expect a tomato plant
you don't expect a jalapeno pepper plant
or an oak tree or anything like that
you'd think something's wrong if that
happened wouldn't you again nature has
certain regularities that are built into
it
um because god arranged things that way
according to thomas
so
now let's move to animals
what's what's distinctive about animals
that separates them from plants
yeah
move from place to place
yeah i mean plants are
pretty much stuck where they are i mean
you could say well what about the ones
that float on the water
well they're floating right they're not
they're not actually like paddling along
and there are some plants that do things
like
insects you know venus fly traps
but it's pretty pretty rudimentary isn't
it whereas you know
i think pretty low level animals um bugs
bugs can do an awful lot
you know
that mosquito that that's bothering you
or that fly that's bothering you that
you're trying to kill
they're pretty smart aren't they they're
pretty good at avoiding getting killed
by you
and you have this big brain and all this
technology that you can use like flies
waters and you know raid and pick
whatever else you want and yet that
little bug can just fly around and avoid
your your efforts to to do it in
um then you know when you go to sleep
they can even eat off of you the
mosquito the fly
that's pretty complicated and again
where did where did all of this
complexity where did all this regularity
come from thomas would say
those things have their natures
they have their own sort of structure
their own sort of you know pursuing
their their ends
um
and that's coming from the eternal law
like he says all things participate
somewhat in the eternal law
insofar as
from it being imprinted on them
just like the corn
has a certain
genetic
code that unfolds you know they call it
going from the genotype to the phenotype
the genotype is just the code the
phenotype is the actual
thing that you can you can look at it's
realization you don't expect a corn
plant to turn out to
look you know bare tomatoes
why not because it has a certain
structure a certain pattern a certain
order imprinted on it
likewise the fly
it's going to avoid you if it doesn't
it's a defective fly
right the mosquito is going to bite you
at least the
the males are the females that fight
it's the females right male mosquitoes
don't
so if you have a female mosquito and
it's not biting you
there's something wrong with it
it's made to do that
it has a nature imprinted on it they
derive their as he says respective
inclinations
they
again is the eraser as a physical object
say to itself
it's time for me to fall now
it doesn't do that it doesn't have a
brain it doesn't have a mind
does the mosquito actually think to
itself
what should i do today
visit the other mosquitoes
it's an awfully nice day
so blood could be nice
um it doesn't doesn't ponder these sort
of things the way we do sometimes right
should i go do my work now or should i
just hang out mosquito you know it
desires the blood um because it's
actually going to use it i think in part
of the egg production process isn't it
i'm not quite sure
but it wants it it has an inclination
and what is its inclination
to its proper acts and ends to
what it is that that thing does
and what it is that makes that thing in
the way that it can be
happy or content
and you know you can think about this
with plants again
plants need certain
certain basic conditions don't they
and if you don't give them those basic
conditions how do they do
okay
sometimes they die
um
sometimes they linger for a long time it
makes you feel bad you don't have a
plant in your dorm room that your dorm
room doesn't have enough light and then
the plant kind of gets all sickly and
pale and starts withering up
now you know you don't have to actually
feel bad
when it comes down to this it's not a
person it's not even the animal
but it can't thrive it can't attain its
its ends
animals have pets
and the animals all have the same ends
bless you yeah
yeah those are those are some certain
basic ends that you can't say in general
they all share
but then when you get to the level of
specificity what is it that actually
consists in thriving for them
well think about insects for example
again
think about the difference between
different kinds of wasps and beets
now again we're not attributing sort of
consciousness to them we're not saying
that they actually think about this sort
of thing like they do in cartoons and
talk with each other and debate they're
good but
there are solitary wasps right there are
wasps that don't live in colonies
they just live by themselves
and they're they're basically interested
in reproducing
they're sort of like machines that go
out and many of them prey on spiders so
they'll go and find a spider or a
caterpillar or something like that and
they'll sting it usually they paralyze
it they lay their eggs in it and then
often take it back to a nest and then
you know the eggs hatch
the other
arthropod the spider or the
caterpillar or whatever
and you know it'll sting you if you mess
with its um nest
they'll sting you right but they're not
interested in stinging very much are
they
they're mainly interested in attaining
that end of reproducing
and they're not really the it's mostly
the female wasps who do things right
it's mostly female
ants and bees and wasps and all these
social animals that do anything kind of
interesting
the female is really only interested in
the male for one thing
to mate to reproduce
and then to feed it's young
and if you can say that that wasp was
happy
that's what makes it happy
that's attaining a test
now
what about more complicated
sorts of insects well think about
honeybees
honeybees
what do they like to do
they're not really stinking people
either are they
yeah and that's a you know pretty
involved process they fly out and they
get on the flowers and they they not
only want the pollen they also you know
like the nectar
and then they come back and they
communicate with each other they do
these dances that you know scientists
have been sort of unraveling uh they're
pretty complicated they buzz around and
you know they say well there's a flower
or a patch about you know 60 yards off
this direction and they use the sun to
navigate
um
pretty neat stuff and then they make a
lot of honey and if you ever like look
at
a bee's
hive there's all these different kinds
of cells there's different kinds of
honey
and different
you know types of you know little cells
where things are stored and they've got
you know three basic kinds there's the
queen who what's her job
yeah reproduce lay eggs and she's
usually a little bit bigger than the
other ones um
and there's usually only one queen
another queen comes about then she's
gotta
take them off or fight to the death of
the first queen
usually they take off and then there's
all these these workers
and then there's the males and the males
basically are just there to help out
with reproduction and then they kick
them out of the nest let them die
called drones we talked about somebody
being a drone
you know
are those male bees really unhappy no
they did their thing they reproduced
that was their purpose
um they're not you know out there
complaining you know picket signs unfair
unfair
we deserve our honey too or anything
like that
and the female
worker bees what makes them happy and so
far as bees can be happy finding the
flowers
doing all those sorts of things
bees can feel another thing too they can
get angry right
like if you ever go up to a bee's nest
and shake it a bit
how's that panda
yeah that doesn't
don't get a stick and start poking it
because what do they think you're doing
they think you're trying to break in to
take their honey or kill their queen and
then they follow
certain ends as well protection
and they do certain distinctive ads they
come out do they try to reason with you
now now now
this is our hive
maybe you didn't fully understand
do they
try to push you away
no they do their thing they sting you
and they actually sacrifice themselves
because you know bees when they sting
it kills them to do so
wasps are a little at a bit of advantage
because they don't have barded stinger
so they can sting you over and over
again
another thing about yellow jackets
yellow jackets are you know when you get
stung
in late summer
it's probably a yellow jacket
in part because yellow jackets are very
aggressive
they're actually carnivorous
well they're actually fairly ominous
they'll eat just about anything
and they tend to outstrip their food
supply and get really agitated and then
start devouring themselves around august
september so things get pretty horrific
inside yellowjackets
and
it gets even worse too i i found this
out by by any chance
because i was cutting the grass and one
of them came and it was buzzing around
me so i you know
knocked it away and stung me
if they sting you if a yellow jacket
stings you it will inject you with a
poison just like every other kind of bee
right
social insect
well that actually has a
chemical in it that will cause you to
produce pheromones
produce uh you know scent
and that scent tells the other yellow
jackets come here and sting this person
and so
they will and this is part of their this
is part of their their nature part of
what makes them what they are um they'll
come and they'll they'll sting me pretty
badly and then you'll go somewhere else
and you'll be like i'm okay now and then
you go to the back door and there's a
whole cloud that i'm just hovering there
waiting waiting for you to come out so
they can
sting what's going on there
again that has to do with the way that
they're designed and that that you know
that does actually kind of fulfill
an end when it first happened to me i
was like how do they know i'm here
do they talk with each other
no it's just it's just chemical it's
just um you know pheromones
being transferred
but it does serve a kind of m so if all
these things can be built into animals
now we go to a higher level what about
us
don't we have some sort of
ends
built into the fabric of
our distinctive way of being
thomas says yes so that's where we get
to the natural
law
so let's look at this question now after
all that long
discussion whether there is a natural
law
he says
we can say that there is a natural law
in part because
he says all things are subjected to
divine providence and they're ruled and
measured by the eternal law so all these
things partake of it
as they have these respective
inclinations do we have inclinations
do we have certain basic drives
and we're going to look at some of these
in a little bit more detail yeah we do
have certain basic drives do we have
certain
distinctive ad certain things that human
beings do
that are distinctive to us as a species
what would you say those are
yeah it's like overconfident abilities
like being able to reason and thank you
yeah and you know
the apes do some of that sort of stuff
for dolphins yeah to some extent but
nothing like us you know when an ape
builds a super computer then maybe we'll
start you know taking that seriously and
saying you know when dolphins which you
know have this gigantic brain most of
that brain is actually devoted to sonar
it turns out
so if sonar was actually some way in
which you could build technology and
communicate with each other
and build a whole society
maybe we take it a bit more seriously
that there there are sort of our rivals
with this but yeah you're right our
cognitive abilities
um what else do we do that's distinctive
to us that animals don't do except in
cartoons
yeah i mean animals do communicate with
each other but their range of
communication is much
um more limited than ours is
i mean no animal actually asks about
language
you know animals aren't bilingual either
it's not like an animal says
you know it's not like a dog says i need
to learn what those cats are saying over
there because i think they're talking
about me i better learn some cat
language
it just doesn't happen it doesn't it
wouldn't occur to them to do that
so language is a key thing
what else are there are there other
things that we do
that um
are really distinctly human these are
great things
thomas would love to hear language
rationality cognitive abilities but are
there other things that set us apart
it's sometimes interesting to think
about those too
i'll get you started i actually brought
this up in a lecture i gave up at the
culinary earlier this week
we're the only animal that cooks
i mean there are some animals that do
modify their food
in certain ways so that they can take it
in you know flies for example
do their digestion actually large part
outside of their body which is kind of
gross
frankly speaking but you know what
they're doing is kind of cooking the
food but they're not actually like
getting out you know
a pot or a pan and slicing things up and
mixing ingredients together and saying
how can i make this taste better we do
do that don't we
that's distinctive human behavior
i guess you could ask could you teach it
you know a chimpanzee to cook
i suppose you know
maybe they could get a taste for certain
things i like ginger and this
but that's us
what else what are other things that are
just totally distinctively human
well all about like
things like going to school getting
married like traditions that
yeah okay that's a lot of stuff right
there going to school and this ties into
those cognitive abilities we have to
develop those and that's made possible
because of speech
so going to school getting married
i mean there are animals that do made
for life but they don't have a ceremony
for that do they
with this ring i need wed
you know my beautiful mockingbird wife
they don't do that yeah
like um ourselves
yes
and again can you can you turn animals
onto that sort of thing
yeah i mean you could you could get a
chimpanzee and they're very curious and
they might like getting dressed up but
they don't actually do that in the wild
do they
um
we actually impose it on a lot of
animals that don't like it like you know
cats and dogs cats and dogs don't really
like being dressed up
but we make them do it anyway especially
with the kids
um
i remember we used to shove my dog into
a pair of shorts
what was the third thing that you said
so i just said anything like traditions
traditions yes we have culture
um and again you know if we look at the
higher apes they they do have you know
bands
certain things get cast on and become
kind of traditions but i mean that's
integral to us
and humans have been doing that for a
very long time
yes religion you don't find animals
let's say we take very sort of
early types of religion you know
involving say
um some sort of cult with sacrifices and
it's you know statue that's supposed to
represent some sort of deity
you don't find dogs doing that you don't
find lions who are you know the top of
their food chain doing that
you don't find dolphins doing that
you only find human beings doing that
um only human beings bury their dead
with things well i mean most animals
don't even bury the god anyway but we
very we very early on bury the dead
with things that shows the you know the
existence of beliefs in the afterlife
like flowers or possessions um bury them
in certain ways like in a fetal position
or in a laid out position
we are symbolic creatures
so that is part of our
our inclinations
these are things that that children play
at
these are things that are
part of the fabric of who we are it's
not just our higher cognitive abilities
and those are really important
it's also these things like passing on
traditions like cooking like religion
you could probably say we're also the
only animal who truly laughs
who engages in things that try to make
each other laugh i mean hyenas make a
sound like laughter but it's not
actually laughing even though the
cartoons you know
try to make it seem like that
so that's all in some
way part of the fabric of who we are of
what we are the kind of beings we are so
the natural law is going to be connected
with this and he says
among all others the rational creature
is subject to divine providence they
turn a law in the most excellent way
how so
we actually like thomas says partake of
a share of providence
and again this is a this is a
theologically informed perspective right
um thomas sees us as being above the
other animals not just by having these
greater abilities
but by being made part of the
part of the process
having what we do main part of the
process sort of we get to we get to be
in the entry level positions in the
divine bureaucracy you might say right
starting out in the mail
or wherever else you have to start out
but we we get to be parts of them
um how are we private both for itself
one one's own being
and for others
so it says wherefore it has a share of
the eternal reason whereby it has a
natural inclination it's proper end in
and
so
our natural inclinations are not just to
preserve our own lives or to make
ourselves happy or something like that
they're also
provided you know we haven't gotten
screwed up in the process they're also
for others they're also directed towards
others
that's distinctively human too
um it's interesting they've done these
you know nature films and they've found
you know like water buffaloes they don't
actually always abandon the one that got
you know chased by the lions and attacks
sometimes they'll come in and they'll
attack the lions and save it
but we do that sort of thing fairly
routinely
so um
we do have a natural law
now what we want to do is we want to
clarify
these other kinds of law that thomas
talks about
the natural law tells us to do certain
things
but it's very general so it's not like
law out there
you know like the law that governs um
speeding on on route 9
government's speeding pretty much
everywhere else right if you speed and
you get caught you get a certain kind of
ticket it's all determined by by laws
made public
is there to preserve the common good
natural law is a lot more general
so then we get to what he calls human
law
and this is the kind of law that we're
used to thinking about
the actual determinate laws
in our society
and these can be
more or less well made more or less well
put together i mean have any of you ever
run into a law that you think is unjust
or unfair
ever
people you know complain about laws all
the time um
what do you mean like laws like just
created by our government our laws like
by governments human human law where
he's talking about that these are laws
actually created by some sort of
governing body i mean it doesn't
necessarily have to be a democratic
government you could have a dictatorship
and that has its own kind of laws
the communists have their own kind of
laws
rules or whatever set by like schools
yeah
at my high school i had a really strict
like um
like uniform policy okay so like i mean
like we all had to wear i went to
capitol schools we were using farms but
yeah one stupid thing that i that we
were allowed to do was wear earrings
like bigger than a quarter
i don't know what that was supposed to
do at all
yeah but that was one of the stupid
does that would that count underneath
yeah and
how would you measure whether that's a
good good water rule or not
you would compare it to what its
purposes are
and what it actually accomplishes
if the law tends to just aggravate
everybody it's probably not a good law
a good rule
sometimes people actually create laws
just so they can have power over other
people or you know
make their lives miserable i mean that's
not usually the case thank god but
it happens right some laws are created
just to enforce inequalities
um you know i brought up martin luther
king a couple times this semester martin
luther king refers in his letter from a
birmingham jail to thomas aquinas
and this notion of human laws having to
be tested
in accordance with some sort of criteria
that comes from
the natural law
the law that he was talking about
specifically he had to do with
segregation
you know is it okay in a society
sort of arbitrarily set aside some
people and say
they cannot participate in the society
but they have to contribute to it
um
does that strike you as unfair
or unjust
yes
anybody for that anybody saying
inequality yes this is great
i want as much of it as possible so long
as i'm you know not the one getting
screwed over by if you feel that there's
something wrong with that
then that would be an example of what
thomas is calling the natural law within
you
you're not feeling it just because
you're not you know
winning out in it right it's not a
purely selfish thing
when you hear about that that sort of
condition
something inside you says that's not
right
and it may not just be an intellectual
thing it may be a feeling thing too
that's what thomas calls the natural law
being used as a measure for a human law
being able to tell you that that human
law is actually not serving its purpose
it's not well made
not all human laws that we have are
actually well made
you know i'll give you another example
the tax laws
you know taxation determines
what the government has to
you know do things that it means to do
right provide for the common defense you
know you guys all read the
preamble to the constitution you know
sure liberty all these sorts of things
and you guys probably have not been
greatly affected unless any of you have
your own business by my tax laws
and the way that we've got it set up in
the united states
but you know you're all going to be out
there in the workplace in about a year
and a half
well you're not actually close to him
and then you're going to run right smack
dan into it
and you'll find out it's very irrational
in many respects and it's the product of
a lot of compromises between two
political parties neither of whom really
represents the whole of the society very
well
and they don't even represent the whole
the society very well when they do
things in what we call a bipartisan way
they represent their constituents and
their constituents this is the way
political parties work they're not
usually
for the common good
one reason washington didn't want to
have political parties
cautioned after you left office
the tax code might be an example of
something where
you would want to look at the natural
law and think about what actually
strikes one is fair
maybe there are some people who get off
too easy and there are some people who
have too great of a burden you know
these are things that you can discuss
and debate about
and if all you have is the human law
then it's pretty much whatever the
person in power says goes that's that's
why it makes right again right
you have to have some sort of standards
by which to judge whether the human laws
have been well put together or not
or even rules or policies or things like
that um
now we also do need the human laws
though because the natural law is again
it's general it doesn't cover every sort
of case
we do have to in each society in each
even schools and groups we have to sit
down and we have to make rules because
otherwise you can't
again
fulfill some of our ends
one of our big heads is actually living
together without killing each other
or
oppressing each other or
you know
making it impossible for us to cooperate
so the laws do that
i'm going to read you a few other
passages where he's talking about the
human laws and natural laws says
he's talking about the the practical
reason how do we figure out what we
ought to do he says on the part of the
practical reason
each human being has a natural
participation in the eternal law
according to general principles
but not as regards the particular
determinations of individual cases
those are contained in the eternal walk
as you know god knows everything and you
know set everything up and all that
so in a certain way the human laws
if they're designed well also
participate in the eternal law
and that's a good segue
for moving into
this issue
thomas talks about a divine law as well
and
here's where it gets a little bit sticky
um
you know often times when we talk about
not mixing religion and morality the
great fear that people have is
somebody's just going to get out the
bible or the koran and start quoting
some verses and saying see there you go
we don't need to think about this
anymore we're all done that's what we
call the divine command theory
you know thus saith the lord now shut up
and do it
that's not what thomas is advocating
what what he's talking about his divine
law might strike you at first as being
along those lines so i do want to talk
about that in his relationship
he asked this question was there a need
for a divine law
and that's a good question to ask
because you know the picture that we've
put out so far you've got a god we'll
say you know just put aside the question
of whether god exists or not let's just
say we're accepting thomas's views there
is a god he's you know the sort of god
that that christians jews muslims
describe him as you know created
everything of nothing
structures everything cares about the
the creation that you know he's not sort
of a capricious god made things just to
break them or anything he actually cares
about
what's going on and he gave human beings
reason
and certain inclinations so that they
could figure things out
well then why would you need something
else
why wouldn't the natural law
be enough
and he says well the natural law
isn't enough
for a couple reasons
so he says besides the natural and human
law it was necessary for the directing
of human conduct to have a divine law
this for four reasons
um
what are these reasons well he says
first it's by law that that human beings
are directed
how to perform their proper acts in view
of their their last step so let's say we
you know put that in a more contemporary
language
in order to figure out what's going to
make you truly happy
you know you
have to do what's what's right you have
to actually follow you know what's going
to satisfy your your inclinations
and attain your your ends now remember
back to last class
as as the sort of creatures that we are
for thomas
is our our last end is our final end is
what's going to make us fully happy
something in the world
or not
what did thomas say
yeah
yeah so any created good it could be
part of happiness but it's not going to
be the whole thing
the natural law will help us to attain
happiness here
you know for instance the natural law
will tell us you need to get along with
other people
um if you're not actually getting along
with other people you're probably not
going to be very happy right even if
happiness for you just consistent
pleasure
um you're probably not going to enjoy a
lot of pleasure because people are going
to want to take it away from you because
you're irritating them right
so the natural law will help you out
with some things
but it won't actually direct you to the
ultimate end
so a divine law is needed for that so
that's one reason
the second reason he says
the uncertainty of human judgment
especially on contingent and particular
matters
as we get away from the more general
to the more and more particular we can
go wrong a lot easier
and it's not just because
you know we're fallible human beings or
something like that is because
particular things are actually harder to
judge
it's really easy to and think about math
classes right all of you remember
um
having problems and learning how to do
certain things what were the kind of
problems that always bothered well not
necessarily all of you but most of you
the most what were the
what were the kind of problems that you
didn't like to do yeah the long division
problems
oh really
okay
well
that was the one that bothered you the
most
i had all sorts of irrational things
myself like i didn't like you know
ending up with a negative answer but
that was kind of a weird
work on my part what do people complain
about in math class though
and worry about running into tests
what kind of problems yeah fractions
wow
well i guess fractions are hard to deal
with
what is it
word problems
yeah why why do people dread word
problems
word problems are sometimes ambiguous
aren't they
they like you said they could be
interpreted in multiple ways um
i suppose for actions in long division
you know it's possible to get things
wrong you know because they're
more complicated ideas right
um and that's sort of along these lines
but it's not quite the same thing as
things being ambiguous if your teacher
writes word problems badly
you can't figure out how to solve it
okay
and there's certain situations when we
get away from the very general we start
getting into the nitty-gritty thomas has
a great example a little bit later on in
our
question 94 he's talking about
giving back
something in return this is a classic
problem
in general if somebody gives something
to you and says hold on to this for me
when they ask you for it you should give
them the thing back right
like you know a weapon for example
what if they say
i'm going to need my gun back because i
want to go in and shoot up my workplace
should you give him the gun
now
you know you notice you're you're
sort of going against the general rule
that you always want to return once was
given to you right so now
your inclination is right though thomas
says
it would be the wrong thing to do
why because there are certain
particulars involved and you have to be
able to look at those particulars so
human law sometimes screws it up doesn't
it
it would be helpful on certain matters
particularly very murky matters to have
some divine help wouldn't it
we have some sort of you know
uh statement from above okay here's what
we need to do in this sort of situation
like think about
thomas doesn't use this example here but
this is a great example
should you forgive
people who harm you
one of the distinctive things that you
find in christian thought
is this emphasis on
forgiveness
not every religion preaches that too by
the way
or preaches it to the same extent
and
not every moral theory would necessarily
go along with that you know if you're a
utilitarian there could be some good
purpose behind forgiveness you know it
could serve some
general happiness thing but not
necessarily maybe it's better to you
know when people screw up you come down
hard on them
and if they cross you
maybe
it's better that you you know cause them
some pain so they'll you know return
more pleasure later
well you know the divine law stressed
forgiveness over and over and over and
over again
even by the way
that's not something unique to
christianity if you look at the the
jewish scriptures you know before the
new testament you will find injunctions
to forgive you'll find it even in the
jewish world
but
less of an emphasis on it
how would we know
that that's really something that the
natural law requires of us
if
something didn't come along to clarify
that for us
that's one of the purposes of the divine
law to give a little bit of
clarification on these these particulars
um
he says um
here's the third one
human beings can make laws in those
matters in which we're competent to
judge
now what do we actually get to see about
another person
why is it that you might not know people
as well as that you think you do
you might be surprised by their good
behavior or their bad behavior
yeah you can't really like tell what
they're thinking or what they really
feel all the time
yeah i mean you can tell a little bit
about what they're doing they can't be
like in their mind yeah
thomas puts it in terms of you can't
know another person's heart but who can
again in this this sort of theological
schema
of god
so thomas talks about interior
dispositions
in addition to actions he says
human beings are not competent to judge
of interior movements that are hidden
but only have exterior acts which appear
um
we you know we get to see the outsides
of other people and you can actually you
know start to infer some things about
them after a while right if somebody
screws you over
each time that you you deal with them
or you get into a conversation with them
and every time you're in a conversation
they try to one-up you
you can figure out after a while that
you don't want to hang out with that
person and that there's something wrong
inside of them right
it's not just a bunch of exterior apps
but do you really know what's going on
with them
you can't like open up their head and
look inside and see what's going on can
you
can't peer into their soul
so the divine law he says
human laws can only look at exterior
things did you follow a law didn't you
they can even you know if somebody's
dumb enough to say i didn't follow the
walk as i hate the law they can you know
judge some interior things
then but for the most part they can't so
the divine law comes along
and the divine law like he says
can tell us about
what we need to do in order to have
virtue because it knows human beings a
bit better
than
these
in part because it's coming sort of from
god
you know in a more direct way than the
natural law which is built into our
nature we use reasons to understand
um so again we think about the example
of forgiveness
aristotle said you should get angry at
sometimes right
and yeah you can forgive some people but
if you actually read aristotle carefully
he'll say ah there's a lot of cases
where you shouldn't forgive people as a
matter of fact you're doing the right
thing by not forgiving bad people
what does christianity teach
yeah you should even pray for your
enemies now that's a weird thing to say
you should pray for people who hate you
you should like wish them well
even knowing that they're probably going
to remain complete bastards you know and
still try to get you and all that
i mean it's pretty
tough stuff to hear isn't it um do you
think the natural law would tell you
that
would you you know sitting by yourself
in some determinate situation using the
reason that you've been given to come to
the conclusion that yeah that person is
mean to me but instead of being mean to
them which is what one of my
inclinations would be my natural
inclination right somebody's mean to you
don't you want to be mean to them
i know i do
um
the divine law comes along and says you
should forgive and not only should you
do it this time you should do it at
other times because that's going to
build up the kind of habit within you
that'll make you a happier person
and a better person
and it may not even change that other
person too
they may continue to do what they do
that's not really your your concern
the divine law would come along and help
you towards certain kinds of virtues
that the natural law by itself would
wouldn't get you to
the fourth one he says
bless you human law cannot punish or
forbid all evil deeds
why not well when you try to
do away with all evils you also end up
doing away with a lot of goods too
human law is kind of a blunt instrument
it's difficult to write law as well
so that they'll actually
attack what's wrong what's bad
and not also screw some some things up
that are good too but i think you can
probably think of some examples
when do we usually make
laws or rules
forbidding something yeah usually like
after the problem has occurred
yeah
um
i'm trying to think of a good example
the thing that came to mind immediately
was duis and drunk driving
that's maybe not the best example but
let's look at it and we'll see if we can
think of another example like that
when i was a kid
you
could drink a lot and drive
i don't mean like a kid like you know
you know high school kid or something
like that because they are already
starting to pass laws then
um but there wasn't that recognition
that it was really dangerous to let
people get out and get on the road all
liquored up
and i grew up in wisconsin and wisconsin
was a pretty hard drinking state and it
was even more heart-drinking back then
it actually leads the nation still in
brandy consumption is pretty close to
you know being on top of beer
consumption believe it or not
and
people were getting in a lot of
accidents
and so then you know what did they do
they passed laws because i mean there
were some people who just like get out
of the bar
after drinking you know the whole night
totally drunk and then drive home right
and nobody really thought much about it
just about trying not to hit anything
but they did hit things and so then you
know there were pushes we need to have a
law about this
and
predictably enough the laws were very
sweeping and
they they came down pretty hard and it
didn't curb a lot of the drunk driving
there's still some problems with it
right
you can't completely eliminate people's
bad behavior but you can
you can make it
a lot smaller
did that have any bad bad effects
i mean now it's i think 0.08
in most states
is that what it is in new york
how much do you have to drink
to blow a point away
very much right
um and it does have a good effect in
that you know it keeps people from being
very drunk and dry because you know if
you had just more than a few drinks
you're going to blow way over that
but does it make a lot of people who
actually are not prone to
drunk driving worried
or reluctant to engage in
social occasions does it
keep people i know people who will
sometimes say
i'm not going to go to that because you
know i would probably have three glasses
of wine because i'd be there for a while
and then you know
you gotta find somebody else to drive me
home
that seems a little strange doesn't it
but people actually do do that that's an
example not a very great example but
that's an example where
the law which is trying to curb some
sort of evil
it actually roots out some goods as well
you know conviviality
can you think of any other rules where
like somebody had to clamp down
and
it screwed things up for everybody else
yeah
well like what they're trying to do now
they're trying to uh pass them off so
that we have don't have the right to
bear arms anymore oh yeah i mean if they
repress it then that's making a lot less
vulnerable
yeah there's i mean this is a
long-standing debate this has been going
on for uh several generations where um
there is a genuine problem with with
people shooting each other in this
country we have a much higher rate than
than some other
civilized countries you know other
liberal democracies that are sort of on
the scale of development that we are
um
and
so there's a lot of you know provisions
to try to pass what we call this gun
control right
and within most major cities you can't
walk around with
you know all sorts of guns
if you do you generally probably a
criminal
or you're you're an authorized you know
person like a police
officer or something like that
um
yeah there are proposals to
like ban handguns all together let's
just let's say we stick with candidates
don't complicate it by bringing hunting
rifles and and all that and we don't
complicate it by saying you know
automatic weapons because i don't think
anybody's gonna ask you in favor of
anybody can have any automatic weapons
so we're just talking about handguns
you can pass laws that totally ban all
handguns
we could do this for the whole nation if
we wanted to
be very tough to enforce but but it
could be done
um
would that rule out certain
goods in this case we actually do have a
constitutional right in which which that
would fracture that would just by itself
taking away people's constitutional
rights causes all sorts of social
discord
and that's that's a bad that's taking
away a good thing right
you could also make you know arguments
that people do like well if you do that
then the only people that are actually
going to have guns are going to be the
people who don't follow the law and then
some people can't protect themselves and
there are cases where
where
people do legitimately protect
themselves with handguns right
look in the
newspapers or magazines
so the law can be a bit heavy-handed
with respect to that okay you know does
that mean that we shouldn't have any
laws altogether because sometimes laws
have unintended consequences
no and we would actually still have to
do sort of a balancing thing there we'd
have to decide well
does the evil
that is being prevented
outweigh the
collateral damage that's coming with it
if it does then maybe we still pass the
law anyway
you know
like we did with the drunk driving laws
because the collateral damage is pretty
small compared to the evil that we're
preventing
but the gun control is a little bit
tougher i think
the arguments are a lot more complicated
aren't they
um
now i don't think the divine law tells
me much about gun control
some people may they induce bible
passages to try to make an argument
about gun control but i i think there's
probably going to be some troubles with
that but there are plenty of things that
the divine law
over time did tell people that were
wrong
that they didn't seem to be getting
and because the bible
you know came to them and people were
actually following it
um
they they realized it wasn't it wasn't
good i'll give you an example actually i
was saying handsome
that you may find kind of funny
um
he wrote a king of ireland while he was
archbishop of canterbury so he's you
know he's a bishop he's in charge of you
know teaching about
the faith and he's charging about
teaching about the divine law
and archbishops were pretty high up so
they could call kings on the carpet so
he writes this guy i think his name is
weird talk and he tells them
hey i've heard about something that's
going on over there
and you shouldn't be doing it i know
it's a lot of fun for you
but um i don't think that you should be
doing it and you're the king so you
should probably make sure that this
isn't happening
what he's complaining about i don't know
if this is actually historically the
case or not he says you guys are
swapping your wives
you're um trading them out with each
other just like you people getting off
one horse and on to another and that's
not right
you know and then he says to him here's
where the divine law would come in i
mean the natural law would tell you
that's not a good idea too but sometimes
we don't get the natural law
he tells them you know if you want to
know you're not supposed to do that you
can either read the scriptures or have
somebody else read them to you
and that's how he talks to this this
king that would be an example of
something where the divine law is being
very clear
about um look this this just can't go
this is something that's bad for you
it's bad for them it's bad for your
subjects
um you didn't seem to get it with the
natural law as a matter of fact your
human law that you're enacting over
there in ireland seems to say this is
a-okay
so then the divine one has to come in
and clarify things
so
thomas does think that there is a need
for a divine law one thing i do want to
point out right before we
finish up with this part
these are gonna these are gonna be
saying more or less the same thing
this is gonna be a bit more specific in
certain things
um and the natural law can get murky for
us
because we
often tend to be
you know disordered in our desires
we're not you know 100
whole and and
rational all the time so the divine law
think of it as sort of like
a support system for the natural law
well where is thomas really putting his
attention
it's primarily
in the natural law
because
if you're functioning well
the things that are being talked about
in the bible
like you know think about the ten
commandments what are what are some of
the ten commandments that have to do
with what you ought to do with other
people
yeah don't murder anybody right um well
you didn't you know
if you
didn't get that if like your you know
things weren't working for you right or
your society said kill anybody you like
so long as they don't matter you know
then it would be good to have the bible
to come along and say
you know don't kill anybody don't murder
people
but you could actually just consult the
natural law and figure that out couldn't
you
if you're being honest with yourself
your conscience could convict you even
if you didn't have some sort of
religious authority
because they're telling the same thing
what was another one
yeah
and you know adultery how would we sort
of reconceive that now don't you know
don't cheat in in
relationships
don't seduce anybody else out of their
relationship
and again do you need the bible to
actually tell you that i mean if you do
you're pretty hard up
right if that's the only reason
why you're not going out and sleeping
with you know other people's spouses
then you really do need the divine love
but you know if you think about it and
you think boy this is not a smart thing
to do this is actually hurting people
this is damaging relationships this is
not good for me over time you would be
using the natural law
you could figure that out on your own
thomas things
let's think about one of the other ones
don't steal
again
if things were screwed up for you and
you know somebody came up to you and
says look it says here in the bible
don't steal
and it doesn't just say it here it says
in a whole bunch of other places too
and that kept you from stealing that
would be good right
but could you figure that out on your
own
i think you probably could and thomas
thinks you could too because that's part
of the natural law as well
so
what i want to talk about now
is this weird word that he calls the
full maze all right
that's a kind of walk
this is in article 6 of question
91
whether there's a law in the fullness of
sin and why why do we have this weird
word because nobody's quite sure how to
translate it well frankly and i don't
know how to translate it well to make
sense and we'll just call it that and
it's basically something like
um
for us
following our
our pure animality
detached from reason when reason has
become defective
and so he says when he's considering
this
um
everything participates in the eternal
law
even the instincts that animals have
participate in the eternal law so he
says under the divine law gamer various
creatures have various natural
inclinations
so what is as it were a law for one is
against the law for another
and he uses the example of a dog and a
sheep or other unique animal and he
talks about fierceness never forget
little lab dogs or stuff like that most
dogs are great fears right i used
a little bit earlier
take a stick poke a dog with it
they'll bite dead stick won't they
now go ahead and do that to a sheep
and you won't get quite the same
reaction run away
it's got different sets of instincts
doesn't it
and each animal
has built into it a set of basic
instincts that make it what it is that
produce the behavior that's
characteristic of it
so
you know think about a lion what are
what are some of the typical lion
behaviors
that you'd associate with
eating out of their hand
yeah i mean lions are not vegetarians
you can try to make them vegetarians but
it's not going to work because
they're designed they're designed to do
that
let's say we take it you know her her
laborious animal
like a horse
can you feed a horse meat
i suppose you could but you know
you'd screw up the horse as a result
but there are legendary things that you
know i don't think there's any basis to
this whatsoever but there's some legends
about people feeding horses
meat
um how do lions behave
how do they get their knee
yeah
they are i mean go go and start messing
with a lion
and
the horse will probably take off i mean
the horse knows you're a predator right
right off the bat this is one of the
things they teach in horse training to
be aware of the fact that the horse
by looking at you you know you've got
eyes in the front of your head
that means you're a predator
you're coming towards it you're big and
tall
you're a predator
it'll take off
that's a natural instinct
what about a lion
approach a lion in the
probably not a good idea thank you
violence territory
yeah well they are territorial horses
actually and sometimes have territorial
things
um how do lions live together
we have all sorts of crazy things like
crows or a murderer and
wolves dogs are in packs
i guess cats are all in prides maybe if
you have a whole bunch of house cats
together
i don't know um
flock of sheep right
um
do you guys know how it works in the
lion world it's actually kind of brutal
you know there's there's like one top
lion the the male lion and then there
may be a few younger ones with him
fairly rare and then there's the females
who actually does
yeah and then there's all these cups
and
the thing of the males is basically like
being tanks you know like the armored
vehicles you know the guns on them um
kind of unwieldy they're not doing a lot
of the hunting because they're so
massive they don't they can't chase
things down quite as quite as well
as the females can but the males are
really good at fighting one one kind of
thing in particular you know what it is
what's that
no lions when you put lions and tigers
together tigers are a lot bigger than
lions and they rip them pretty badly
but luckily they don't occupy the same
territory yeah each other other male
lions
because the the
rogue males who come in and they want to
take over the
pride
and if they succeed one thing that
they're going to do is kill every one of
the cubs
it's just part of their nature
that you know part of reproduction and
you know passing on their their genetic
heritage and the the females will often
you know if the the rogue male comes in
and defeats the main male
he'll often get killed in the process
um
sometimes the females will be killed in
the process defending the cops they can
be pretty bloody actually
lions are like us
they're one of the
animals that engages in the most
interest
intra
predation
where it's lions killing lions
another animal that is sort of up there
with us like that
believe it or not chimpanzees
chimpanzees are so aggressive towards
other chimpanzees that they will
actually make strategic decisions to
like go and hunt down another
group of chimpanzees and wipe them out
they're so much like us
we are unique
really in that respect not not
everything that's unique about us is
necessarily good
right it's part of why the natural law
is so important to keep those sort of
things in check
now um
so animals all have their own their own
particular natures and they all have
their sort of law
and
thomas says
the law of man
which by the divine ordinance is a
latitude according to his proper natural
condition is that he should act in
accordance with reason that's what it is
to follow natural law to use the faculty
of reason that's been given to us
what happens if we don't use the faculty
of reason
well we are animals
we do still remain animal we still have
the same sort of drives that other
animals
do
and so he says um
this very inclination of sensuality what
do you mean since my sensuality is our
animal nature you know what are the
things that we have basic drives towards
that we desire you know we want food
we want shelter
we want security we want sex
we want
power
um
now we start to get more distinctively
human things we want to be on top we
want to win
we want to
attack things that make us afraid or run
away from them
and if reason isn't calling the shots
then we revert to our animal nature but
our animal nature isn't really like the
other animals in some respects we're
warps
when we become just mere animals we're
way worse than any animal because the
animals got it you know its own sort of
regulatory system
it's it's nature that
was built into it
i mean sometimes they'll help strip
their territories you know
rabbits go to australia too much of the
grass you have a rabbit problem
there weren't rabbits there before
and then you find something else that
preys on them and then they get brought
back into check
what about us
if we don't control our desires
we're much more dangerous than any other
animal
not just to the other animals but to
each other
we can think of all sorts of ways to
hurt each other that animals never
devise
sometimes we actually like you know look
at the other animals we're like
uh that's not a bad idea it could hurt
somebody that way
you know
that's what you know all you have to do
is like scan on the internet a little
bit and run across all sorts of examples
of that we can come up with all sorts of
ways in which we go wrong when we don't
follow the natural law
then we're stuck with these
sort of disorder desires that we have
within us ourselves yeah so this bonus
like kind of once you let your animal
nature take over you you start using
reason to fulfill those animal desires
right and that's just that instinct
that's another good good point
when we talked about this with plato
right you can have your appetites and
you have reason there's a third part
we'll leave that out of the process
right
and when you're properly functioning
reason is calling the shots and it's
telling the appetites hey you get to
indulge yourself but only this much
because the absolutely
i want this and this and this and this
and this and if the appetites are
calling the shots this is again why
we're so dangerous
when our appetites are calling the shots
we don't stop the way other animals
would
you know dogs don't actually
go into murderous rages and then hunt
down the families of other dogs who
cross them
human beings do
sometimes they're not even in a
murderous rage sometimes it's just
business you know gotta eliminate the
competition
um criminal enterprises do that sort of
thing
so yeah reason can become subordinated
in the human being to our basic desires
and i want to i want to hit on why
thomas thinks sometimes we can go wrong
with this sort of thing
he talks about this a little bit later
on in
question 94 where he's talking about the
natural law
and he's dealing with questions like
is the natural law always working inside
of us
you know if we've got these inclinations
how do we actually go back
um
how is it that we end up you know
lapsing into this sort of thing
and he says um when it comes to the
practical reason
how we figure out what we ought to do
what's the good thing what what our
course of action on today
we don't always know
what we ought to do sometimes our
practical reason
can
be defective it can it cannot actually
lead us to what it's supposed to do
what can actually screw us up with these
sort of things
he says
there can be certain obstacles
that arise
some of these could be in terms of
knowledge
so what keeps you from knowing what what
the good is he says
well your reason could be perverted by
passion by by
the emotional part
so again think of the person who's
got a vicious disposition with respect
to anger
and now they're
off the handle somebody somebody made
them angry
you better look out for them right
because the natural law
is in them but they're not listening to
it are they
they're they're listening instead to
what it is that their
their emotions are telling them
um
people can ignore a reason because of
grief too
or just because of you know the desire
for pleasure
or
a number of other things
um
an evil habit what are what are evil
habits those are the vices
so if you are
intemperate if you characteristically
are self-indulgent you're you're always
you know seeking to have your your
sensual desires satisfied
um think about some of the things that
would
lead you to do in contrary to the
natural law
you know
would you stop with
seconds or thirds
if it's with respect to food
even though the natural lot probably
tell you hey that's enough food for you
leave something for everybody else
no it's a
bad habit or an evil disposition of
nature that means like you know there
are cases where somebody's screwed up we
talked about addiction as an example of
that before
another thing that thomas talks about as
well
is
he talks about the natural law being
able to be blotted out from the human
heart sort of in a way of being made
inactive
by vicious customs
so if you grow up in a society
where people
are for the most part
screwed up
you're going to have a much harder time
actually listening to the natural law
so he uses this example we don't know
that it was actually true
but the ancient
romans thought that this was the case
that the the ancient germans thought
that theft was okay so long as you got
away with it it was good it's fine
um
and everybody else pretty much thought
it was a bad idea
natural losses don't steal other
people's property right
well let's assume that that was actually
the case
that you have a society in which theft
is considered okay so long as you get
away with it uh or so long as you can
you know fight off the person that
you're you're stealing things from how
would you then
look at those sort of matters
would you
think to yourself
well i know that this is what my society
is teaching me
but
um i know that that's not the right way
kind of tough to do that wouldn't it
if everybody else around you is
practicing this and you're seeing
examples of it all the time
it might be hard to actually listen to
the natural law yeah is that where
divine law comes in place then i guess
this is that person yeah it could be
very useful for that for that reason
okay um
you know think about some some other
examples
some more
seemingly innocuous examples
americans are workaholics
compared to other
societies
we uh we tend to put in a lot more hours
and put up with a lot more
sacrifices than to do other people
there's some good things about that
aren't there
i mean we're also pretty productive and
we generate a lot of wealth and
stuff in the process
but do people make bad decisions
when they're balancing work against
other goods
you see people doing that
where do they make those sort of bad
decisions what are some of the other
goods they trade off against that
yeah
family life that's probably the biggest
one um
and family life has to do with
obligations that you actually have to
other people
um you know if you marry somebody
and you
make some kids with them
that's not a morally neutral thing for
somebody like thomas aquinas you're
actually incurring some pretty important
obligations as a matter of fact that's
part of the natural laws we're going to
see in just a minute
so if you're taking work which is a good
thing
again i don't want to say you know
thomas is saying be lazy or you know
let's all be a bunch of confidence or
anything like that
and cool everything
he thinks that work is a good thing but
it ought to be balanced against these
other very important goods and the
natural law can tell you that
now if you belong to a society which is
constantly telling you
you are your job
how how easy is it for you to
say no
no my spouse needs me to be home
i have to watch the kids i need to spend
some more time with my kids
is it easy to do that
that is an inclination
but following that inclination is pretty
tough
if you grow up in a household where
your parents
didn't make the time for your activities
or
came home so burnt out from work that
they couldn't take any interest in your
activities
is it going to be harder for you to do
that for your kids
it will be a bit harder yeah i mean not
insurmountable right and sometimes we
actually have the counter reaction you
say
this is awful i'm not going to be like
that i'm not going to force that on my
kids that's easy to say though because
oftentimes you know we have an intention
following through on it there's a
different manner we often do end up
looking an awful lot like our parents
so there are some things that could end
up
you might say deactivating or suspending
the natural law making it so that it
can't get the traction that it needs it
can't actually steer us in ways that we
want it to
and that you know if we're not following
this
we're going to be following this
because this is part of us as well our
fallen
nature
and like you asked yeah divine law comes
along and helps out with those sorts of
things
by the way
there's really not much in divine law
that thomas thinks if you were
functioning at that top capacity you
couldn't figure out using the natural
law
so there's nothing
say that scripture is teaching or very
little things that scripture is teaching
that if you actually applied your reason
and your reason didn't have all these
impediments you couldn't figure out on
your own
when in fact we're usually screwed up
though aren't we
so that's why the divine law
is needed
for some things
let's now look at what does the natural
law actually teach them so we've had a
lot of sort of vague
you know this and that about it let's
look at
article two
the precepts of the natural law to the
practical reason or the first principles
of demonstrations are the speculative
reasons they're self-evident principles
um now that doesn't mean that we all are
aware of them all the time but there are
things you know that are very general
they cover a lot of situations
speculative reason it would be things
like the whole is greater than the parts
i mean does anybody need that proof to
them
you know
a house is more than the door
you all get that right that's
self-evident um
when we get to particular examples it
starts to get a little bit sticky
sometimes they're moving from the
general to them to particular
now he says that
practical reason works that way too
there's certain lessons like rules or
commands or ideas
that are so fundamental so basic and
when you say them they almost sound like
common sense
um
but they're you know they're sometimes
easy to deviate from as well so he says
a certain order is to be found in those
things that are apprehended universally
what do we apprehend what do we take in
universally well everything that you're
looking at has
being
it's real
it has it has
existence
so the notion of this is included in all
things whatever a person
apprehends
uh he says so as being is the first
thing that falls under the apprehension
so good
is the first thing that falls under the
apprehension of your practical reason
good is the broadest category
there's a lot of different ways in which
things can be good we've looked at that
a lot this semester right
so
the practical reason is directed to
action to doing things to what you want
to do
and it's directed towards ends
so the first principle of practical
reasoning says is good is that which all
things seek after
the first precept of the natural law is
good is
to be done
and
i've done and pursued
that's pretty pretty gentle right that
covers an awful lot of ground that
doesn't give you an awful lot of
concrete guidance and things does it
that's that's something that's built
into the fabric of your thinking
that can be turned off though
you know when somebody actually chooses
to do something and they say i know this
is wrong but i want to do it
because i want to you know i want to do
what's wrong they would be actually
going against this the highest principle
from
practical reason
kind of tough to do usually when
somebody does something like that
they're really seeking some other good
i'd like to do this because i like
screwing people over well then you like
screwing people over and that's what
you're viewing as a good
probably because you derive security
from it or power
or pleasure or something like that
now
this is a really big one
it's almost i i've used this example
before does anybody know google's uh
ethics thing that they would always say
don't be evil
now does that tell you an awful lot
don't be
um i had an interview with this company
last week and they asked me if you knew
about their
strict no [ __ ] policy
what did you say i said i didn't know
about it but i'm all forward to me
the trouble becomes how do you define it
though right
no um well
you know
there may be some paradoxes involved
it all depends on how you define the
terms doesn't it and when it comes to
good and evil it's really a matter of
specification so we need something a bit
more concrete than that so thomas says
okay well let's look now then not just
at being as a whole let's look at human
beings
what are our different levels what are
the different dimensions of human being
and he says
all those things to which man natural
inclination are naturally apprehended by
reason as being good in some way and
consequently as objects of pursuit
they're contraries as evil and objects
of avoidance
what is it that we're naturally inclined
to well let's start with the broadest
thing what do we share in common with
with all other beings
he says there's first of all an
inclination to good
in accordance with the nature which
you and i
have in a court in common with all other
substance
what is it that all beings try to do
besides fulfill their end and
that
what's one thing
not everything he necessarily enjoys
that that is you know
if plants enjoy things they enjoy them
in a very different way than we do but
let's think about plants
what do plants
what do they do
you survive is that what you get yes
okay
all things attempt to continue
all things like he says
desire or seek the preservation of their
own being according to their nature so
you know the nature of this iphone
is just a piece of technology
but you know it does report when
something gets screwed up on it
but you know i mean that's not much of
the inclination you know in any sort of
sense
um
this actually does
hold together
as an object
it's plastic you know actually may hold
together longer than i do because
plastic is hard to break down turns out
this truck you know generally stays
together until i wipe it on the board
plants more complex things react to
their environment they turn towards the
sun
the source of you know nourishment
um they can't move from place to place
which makes them kind of vulnerable
right animals
move from place to place most of them i
mean
there's
oysters staying there for the most part
but most animals move from place to
place seek their food and things like
that they try to continue in being don't
we do that too
don't we do a lot of things for the sake
of survival
yeah um
what else now let's move to a higher
level what do animals do
when plants do this too in a certain way
iphones don't do it when pieces of chalk
don't do it
what do they do
yeah
very good
um
plants do do this
right they have they have ovum and
pollen and
you know they do sexual reproduction and
some
kind of interesting flowers by the way
are the sex parts of plants
you know if you think about it
like turning off flowers i don't know
they're actually a particular part too
they're actually a particular part yeah
and you know pedals are actually adapted
to these
um
and other animals reproduce you know
some of them reproduce in kind of weird
ways like earthworms i guess can you
change their
their sex and you know they
basically don't rub against each other
you know um
insects do all sorts of kind of kind of
interesting things
some of them you know only exist for the
purpose of mating like you know bees
male bees in the hive
the only purpose they have is to mate
with the queen and then after that they
kick them out and the male bees seem to
be okay with it you know because
that's their their inclination
what do some animals do that goes beyond
just making babies
get to hiring what are they what do they
start doing
so like taking care of their babies or
whatever it is they had yeah
now they don't all do this
you know alligators will eat other baby
alligators
a mother alligator will
defend the nest to a certain extent but
sometimes they just bury the eggs and
take off and that's it
they run into their babies they eat them
but you know alligators are kind of low
on the level they're
mammals are
pretty unique
i mean
our
adaptation is making
milk and why why do you need to make
milk well because babies need milk
and
it's a way of passing on
nutrients and do all mammals then
continue to take care of their babies
you know as a matter of fact some of
them will try to kill them too like tom
cats you know you want to keep the
tomcat away from the kittens because
they'll try to kill the kittens too
um but the harder you get up
the more and more caregiving there is
yeah well like dolphins like they don't
it's not just the parents it's like
their whole
pack i guess or whatever you call
behind the scenes
travel it's interesting like how they
all participate in it yeah those are
school of dolphins i don't know i think
yeah that's what fish are referred to
probably oh
too um i mean one thing about
chimpanzees they are pretty brutal
creatures much more brutal than gorillas
you know i mean ever the gorillas really
get a bad rap
um you know watch those planet of the
apes it's the gorillas that are the mean
ones they got a completely backwards the
chimpanzees are the ones who you know
want to
kill each other
but they will take care of others young
and you know what's really interesting
if you look at between species
animals will actually sometimes adopt
babies not even of their species
yeah i saw that
everyone's waiting when is she gonna eat
it yeah wait what
there was another
is
a lot of these animals it turns out that
their instincts
are a little bit less
hardwired
and more needing things to happen in
their environment than we thought you
know one of the shows that i used to
watch with my daughter that i really
enjoyed
was they would do these animal rescues
of
these
these
rhinos and hippos and elephants
and animals like that
wild animals and who lost their their
mothers and you know we're outside of
any sort of pack or pride or anything
like that and they bring them into an
enclosure and then quite often they pair
them up with another animal of a
different species who is also a young
and eventually they start to play
together
so you would think elephants would only
play with other elephants
but actually elephants will play with
rhinos
or we'll play with you know uh names or
things like that they will they will
bond with each other there have actually
been cases with um older animals having
pets at least you know with gorillas
like having kittens
now that's not happening in a while
right but but they do this with
researchers and so it brings out
something within them something that
again
natural law is a matter of inclinations
and we
are not unique in what we show towards
infants yeah
sorry to go off topic but i thought i'd
put this out there i don't know if
anybody here has seen there's this guy
that raised blind cubs from when they
were young oh they're now like a
full-grown male alliance and they play
around with it and then treat him like
he's the leader of the pack they got and
there's that famous video too of that
guy who goes to africa yeah
and everyone's thinking that the lion's
gonna eat him and they said lions don't
remember people you don't don't uh
you know don't go out there because
we're not gonna be responsible and sure
enough he goes out there
and
you see that the video the lion kind of
like creeping up and you're like oh this
would be bad
and then it hugs him
because
again
part of a higher animal nature is this
bonding that takes place
that's just not just to do with
instinct
but with emotion with affection with
something that develops
the third thing that he talks about is
an inclination to the good according to
the nature of
reason
what makes us distinctively human again
and each one of these
takes a fairly determinate
shape
so
you know one of the
if you want to make this a little bit
more specific to continue in being what
can we derive from that
the inclination
or the precept is that
what belongs to the natural law whatever
is a means
preserving human life
um
warding off obstacles
so the natural law says that you should
respect life
human life in particular
because that that is our kind
it doesn't necessarily say well screw
all the other animals do whatever you
want to them thomas isn't saying that
but he is saying there's something
instinctive about this
so when you see somebody um
you know threatening another person and
you feel that that's wrong
that's because there's an inclination in
you that is coming from
you know
our being
that's woven into us and that
inclination is right
when you want to help somebody who is
sick
that's boarding off whatever is you know
an obstacle to human life
whatever is a means of preserving human
life what do we need to preserve our
lives what are our basic needs that we
have
food yeah food and shelter
providing other people
food and shelter not just ourselves you
notice that
this isn't just about our own
self-preservation this is about the
preservation of other human beings
providing other people with food and
shelter when they don't have it
is fulfilling the natural law
depriving them of food or shelter would
be against the natural law wouldn't it
so going and burning somebody's house
down is not just a bad thing because you
know you took away their property it's a
bad thing because you actually took away
their shelter
as they sometimes say when they're being
melanin taking food out of out of my
children's mouths if somebody actually
is doing that by you know whatever
they're doing in the workplace to
somebody else then they're violating the
natural law
you know there's certain basic needs
certain basic things
that the natural law says that everybody
wants to be given
can you think of any others
food shelter
medical care perhaps
i was going to say air but if we like us
you said
yeah i think that's certain
environmental things access to water
could be a matter of the natural law as
well clean air
water you know it's a big issue here
being discussed in new york because of
the fracking in fact you know
are they going to allow these chemicals
to be driven underground to to bring out
other things which makes grip the water
supply
that could be thought of in terms of the
natural law you know
um
let's move on to the next one we have we
have reproduction
and raising young
so you know what does the natural law
actually tell us that we ought to do we
ought to
in fact
have sexual intercourse
otherwise the species dies out right
um we have a natural instinct towards
that and the natural law would tell us
it should be exercised in certain ways
you know for instance um sort of a
radical promiscuity screwing anything
that moves would not be
you know fulfilling that instinct in a
way in accordance with reason i mean
just just think you know today how many
things could go wrong with that
back in thomas's time they didn't have
syphilis you know let alone other other
bees syphilis is
horrific by itself but
you know it's not as common as some of
the other things that we have to worry
about as well right what are some of the
other things you'd have to worry about
just go out and follow your sexual
instinct wherever it happens to be well
how could that go wrong
yeah
yeah i mean you know if you're going to
have children you should actually like
be prepared to take care of them
um
what else why why else is it a bad idea
to
sleep with anybody who will possibly
sleep
it's what it's just growth well yeah i
mean if you set your bar very low then
it's probably not going to be that
pleasurable
so let's say you actually add a proviso
in there sleep with anybody who will
sleep with you who you don't find gross
what else is still
okay now again you're
you're you have a properly functioning
faculty of reason that you're actually
listening to and it's you know
recognizing certain inclinations
there's certain goods that you would
deprive yourself of and also like
you're making a good point to private
other people
by just indulging your sexual appetite
indiscriminately
raising children what is raising
children involved
i mean that's something to think about
with this too does that mean just
showing up
putting food on the table saying all
right
get to it
what do you have to do if you have kids
a lot of responsibility isn't it
something some people have to do
how so
just teach them right and wrong
that's a big one
you know i mean if you're actually
telling your kids
um
go and beat up the other kids and take
their lunch money you're you're not
fulfilling the natural law you're not
raising your kids well all right
actually that wouldn't have been over
here too
if you don't have teachers
then you have to teach your kids
and we can actually farm out a lot of
this
child raising stuff to teachers and
other people day care workers
if you're going to do that you should
probably actually check them out i think
these days if you want to get to the
nitty-gritty of this the natural law
would probably say you should you should
have a good idea of what those in charge
of your kids are actually doing with
them because the kids are ultimately
your responsibility
what else do you have to do is it enough
just to sort of like put up the guard
rails
yeah oh nourishment
nourish them yeah
you mean the screwed her
that's important too what else should
you give children though
yes
it's
parents who don't love their children
and it's tough to love kids sometimes
actually you know quite frankly
you know it takes work sometimes
parents who don't love their children
are actually in thomas's view uh
violating the natural law
and if they thought about it if they
bless you if reason was functioning well
with them they could figure out hey i'm
screwing up i need to fix this i need to
do things differently
sometimes parents have those sort of
moments of
realization and you know what would keep
them from doing that well you know think
about if you're getting the wrong
messages from society if your passions
are disordered it's going to be much
harder to love your children as you want
to
the when we get to the even higher level
the distinctively human level and i do
want to say this is distinctive too we
love our children in ways that horses
and
if we get to the higher level where it
has to do with reasoning he says
there is in every person a natural
inclination to act according to a
certain reason and this is to act
according to virtue so we should in fact
actually cultivate the virtues
if we speak of
virtuous acts then those are going to
involve a lot of different applications
of reason what else though we have a
natural inclination to do two other
things that's really important
two other things that are really
distinctive to us human beings one is to
live in society
now we talked about this before other
animals do have somewhat of a social
organization they don't debate about it
dogs don't say
um should we have a dictatorship
or a democracy
you know what sort of rules should we
make for this pact they just sort of you
know
do things
bees you know do incredibly interesting
things actually answering them working
twice
but ants don't sit down and say is our
society on the right track or not
the other thing that thomas says and
this is where i'm gonna i'm gonna leave
you because i'm actually holding you
over a little bit unfortunately and i
apologize for that
is to
know about god
thomas thinks that that's part of the
natural law that that's something
distinctive to us and there again you
know we're moving into this very
theological dimension so i think that's
a good place to
to stop and to sort of wrap up the
semester